now since the one october shooting of
course we've had the downtown healing
garden here in the valley it's a place
to remember victims
and find solace for several months as
well clark county has worked on a larger
more permanent site
to honor those affected by las vegas
darkest night
bianca holman is live this morning with
how you can give input on clark county's
effort bianca good morning
good morning john so there are
communities like columbine virginia tech
el paso they all have a permanent
structure to memorialize what happened
in their communities
with a mass shooting and so while we
have the healing garden here
of course las vegas we are going to
eventually have a more permanent
memorial for the victims
and survivors of the one october
shooting memorials in other communities
they range from sculptures structures
and museums vegas strong resiliency
staff say this is the first step in a
conversation about the best way to
memorialize what happened
this survey is a critical part of
healing for those impacted
it's important to remember when people
are dealing with trauma or trying to
heal from something
it's important to be validated and for
others to remember
what happened but also to be a place of
healing and of hope
and to honor those that we lost
so here are the details for the survey
it's 15 questions asking what you would
like to experience
at the memorial and when you respond you
rate the importance of education
interactiveness appeal to all ages and
of course some other categories there
now this survey is available till march
14th
and you can take it again with the ease
of on your phone there's a link on our
website that's available and also after
the survey there's going to be several
other meetings
and follow-up surveys before they decide
on something permanent and that location
reporting live from the healing garden
bianca holman 8 news now